hey what's going on everybody
it is july 19th 2021
monday july 19th i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report direct
message do me a favor share our videos
subscribe to our channel
tap the notification bell and see what
happens all right we got a jam-packed
show today
and i think i'm going to basically get
right into it first off
four stories for you uh you're not going
to believe this people
but the dems the democrats they were
saying very different things
about the vaccine say a year ago than
they're saying now
has anything changed in the last year
that might have changed their opinion on
things
is there a different guy in office in
the office of the presidency
over at the white house that might have
flipped their opinions on all these
things
we'll take a look then this one we just
added this story because i saw it about
five minutes before
we went live here but joe biden was
giving a press conference this morning
and you know he gives very very
controlled press conferences with very
limited questions and he knows who he's
going to pick on beforehand then i
suspect
he probably knows the questions and he's
got his note cards in the whole thing
but he went on and on about
misinformation and the types of people
who are spreading this information
what we're going to juxtapose you know i
like to juxtapose
we're going to juxtapose biden's
statement about misinformation
with his campaign launch video where he
claimed trump said the very fine people
on both sides thing
uh after the charlottesville incident
first what trump actually said
we're going to juxtapose those things
post it on the internet then we'll let
you people
decide what's what the third story is
just spectacular
brian stelter this potato guy over on
cnn with his show
unreliable sources he got demolished
yesterday on his own show you know i
don't tweet on the weekends so i don't
see these things until monday morning
but like
it's just incredible uh he brings on uh
this author
and they start talking about the media
and stelter just
i mean he is turned into potato hash
it's just spectacular
and then from a spectacular story to
something that's actually rather
depressing although a sign of the times
the nfl which has seen its ratings just
collapse
uh much like nba over the last couple
years the more that they embrace social
justice
they are going to be playing the black
national anthem
at games this season before the american
national anthem there's no such thing as
the black national anthem and if you
want to figure out a way
to divide a country and have black
people singing one song and white people
singing another song well then they've
done it
so we'll dive into that but first all
right let's talk about vaccines so it's
interesting over the last couple days it
does seem like
covet is back right los angeles has
reinstated the mask mandate
uh maybe someone i know sitting in this
very room right now is
kicked out of a supermarket this morning
for trying to go in
without a mask i'm not you know laying
any blame specifically but anything's
possible
um you know the the decision to to put
the mask mandate back in la
was done by one woman this woman barbara
ferrer
who sort of looks like skeletor's sister
just saying and people have just sort of
had it but what i think is interesting
about the sudden burst of now we have to
worry about covet again is
there was suddenly a lot of talk in the
last 10 days about
elections again right people were
talking about elections people were
really pushing back
on the administration going after social
media organizations social media
companies
for uh spreading misinformation and that
they were gonna basically push facebook
to censor things
so suddenly there was like this
groundswell of anger towards the
administration next thing you know we're
all worried about covet again
and suddenly you got to get booster
shots and
the delta variant and the whole thing
well we've got an interesting
little compilation video here for here
for you this is
uh kamala harris and joe biden in the
course
of the last year before biden was
elected talking about vaccines
and whether or not you should trust the
government
so let's just say there's a vaccine that
is approved and even distributed before
the election
would you get it well i think that's
going to be an issue for all of us
if and when the vaccine comes it's not
likely to go through all the tests that
needs to be ended trials that are needed
to be done
when we finally do god willing get a
vaccine
who's going to take the shot who's going
gonna take the shot
you can be the first one to say put me
sign me up
they now say it's okay and the question
of whether it's real when it's there
that requires enormous transparency
you've got to make all of it available
to other experts across the nation
so they can look and see so there's
consensus this is a safe vaccine
if the president announced tomorrow we
have a vaccine would you take it
only if it was completely transparent
that other experts
in the country could look at it only if
we knew all
of what went into it if donald trump
can't give answers and administration
can't give answers to these three
questions
the american people should not have
confidence but if donald trump tells us
i should
that we should take it i'm not taking it
whoa
i mean it's that sort of skepticism
about what the government
is doing is that misinformation is that
scary bandworthy talk
i mean i think you guys see my point
here they ask you some interesting
questions there
uh well kamala first says uh it's an
issue whether she would take it or not
joe says who's gonna take it is it real
and then uh he would only take it if
it's transparent now what's interesting
is we're hearing in the last couple
weeks that people who are getting sick
again with kovid
it's a good percentage of them i don't
know the exact percentage because it's
almost impossible to get clear
information these days
but a decent percentage of them were
vaccinated already
actually you guys know this ridiculous
story about the texas democrats who were
protesting
their election law so they all got on a
plane unmasked and went to dc
well it turns out that i think four of
them have coveted by the way they have
very mild symptoms and they're going to
be okay
they were all vaccinated just fyi but
now we're hearing that oh
suddenly you're gonna have to get
booster shots every six months
and with the delta variant that even
though the vaccine isn't working
as well as it's supposed to work that if
you get the delta variant and your
vaccine you'll suddenly
not get such a severe case is this the
way any of it was sold to us
again i'm not sitting here trying to be
an anti-vaxxer or an
anti-government nut bag or a conspiracy
theorist
but i'm just listening to the very words
of joe biden and kamala harris before
they were the ones in charge they had
what i would say is a healthy dose of
skepticism skepticism by the way is
something that we all should have
right you should use your faculties and
your ability to think for yourself and
ascertain information from a bunch of
different places
and then figure out what is right for
you and your family that's what they
were for
before they were in charge now they were
they're in charge and they want you to
bow to them
so you must take the vaccine you must
take the booster shot
there's the delta variant now there'll
be the omega variant tomorrow
and blah blah blah blah blah and the
question is
should these people be suspended from
social media
because you know just last week there
she was
jen saki saying that you know if you're
banned from one
social media site for misinformation we
should ban you from all well
it seems like that type of skepticism
that they were promoting back then
might be ban worthy right i mean that
would that would that's almost as bad as
questioning
questioning whether uh an election was
legitimate or if there was any voter
fraud or anything else would we be
allowed to talk about any of these
things
you see what i'm doing here people i
think i think you guys get it you get it
he got it so i think you guys get it too
anyway the same this ain't going
anywhere but i do think that the
the sort of high level version of this
is that the biggest issue with
kovid i would argue at this point is not
covid
the virus i believe the covid the virus
exists
i believe that 97.5 to 99 of people
survive it
i believe that if you don't have
comorbidities you're going to be just
fine now there's a new thing
that the american pediatric institute or
something is recommending masking for
all children above two years old i mean
this is
psychotic stuff and and look how
different the world is
than it was a year and a half ago i am
pretty sure that if any of us
could do that like pull little thanos
not eliminate half the life in the
universe but just
pull little thanos and just go back in
time right if we could just
you know fire up the flux capacitor in
the delorean get the 1.21 gigawatts and
go back to a year and a half
that world i'm pretty sure most of us
would do it because something ain't
right here
and i don't think it's that the biggest
worry is the covid virus i think it's
the virus
of governments and authoritarians that
are rampaging through the west
and tech companies and all of these
things to control what we say and who we
say it to and when we say it and how we
can say it
and then of course because of technology
we can expose the people who are saying
one thing now
when a year ago they were saying
something completely different but if
you think that
sort of lying and dishonesty uh is
something well i got i got even more for
you so i'm going to show you
three videos here pretty quickly this
first video is joe biden
this morning at a press conference
talking about
misinformation and the people who spread
misinformation look at himself look in
the mirror
think about that misinformation going to
your son your daughter your your
relatives someone you love
well that's pretty interesting joe
you're right people that spread
misinformation should look in the mirror
because
if you're spreading misinformation
you're spreading lies and it's not good
to spread lies i think we all know that
now let's look at joe biden's campaign
launch video this is
the video that he launched the day he
announced he was running
for president of the united states and
that's when we heard the words of the
president united states
that stunned the world and shocked the
conscience of this nation
he said there were quote some very
fine people on both sides very fine
people on both sides
very fine people on both sides
i wonder if he left something
out that trump said in that very
same press conference i believe we have
video
and you had people and i'm not talking
about the neo-nazis and the white
nationalists
because they should be condemned totally
but you had many people in that group
other than
neo-nazis and white nationalists okay
yeah there you have it joe biden
prime purveyor of misinformation
what joe biden is doing right there is
now first off of course he's talking
about misinformation as it relates to
kovid
and we all know that fauci has flipped a
thousand times over
and we know that all the democratic
governors that were going out and
partying at french laundry or on
boats or to mexico or wherever while
they lock their people down that these
people are all hypocrites uh but what
joe biden did in that campaign launch
video in some ways that should have
blown up his campaign right there but i
get it we don't we don't have a media
right
so you guys that know the truth have to
sort of feel like you're the crazy
people
because the the masses the brainwashed
masses
just don't get this information so when
trump i mean i'll say this
i've said it before we've we've gotten
some videos on this to go viral on
twitter
uh when trump was saying very fine
people on both sides first off he had
first
done what i just showed you right there
he had condemned the neo-nazis totally
when he was talking about very fine
people on both sides he was talking
about
of both sides of the debate as to what
we should do with these statues in this
case
the statue of robert e lee who was the
confederate
leader obviously during the civil war
and whether we should just tear these
things down
or whether there should be a
counter-monument or a plaque or whether
they should be moved
to museums or the litany of other things
that you could do related to a complex
history that the united states has much
like every other country in the history
of the world
so joe biden launched his campaign with
an
abject 100 percent why
a spread of misinformation related to
what
then president donald trump said uh
regarding
regarding charlottesville so joe biden
is a liar and a misinformation
specialist and you know according to jen
saki and the administration as i just
said we played it last week
they're now flagging videos her words
for facebook the administration is
flagging videos
for facebook that are misinformation you
might say that that is government
coercion of a private company
in regards to free speech which would be
yeah you got it a violation
of the first amendment now i don't know
that any of our systems work anymore i
don't know that the
separation of powers work anymore i
don't know that a true
defense of the bill of rights or the
constitution could be mounted anymore i
mean this is all going to sort of fall
back
on the courts if you want more of that
actually we just
put up part one of my interview with
robert barnes who's
one of the lawyers who's worked with
trump before and he's worked
on the alex jones lawsuit and he's
worked on the kyle rittenhouse lawsuit
and a bunch more
and we discussed some of the ways that
the legal system can work related to
fighting big tech
um but in essence if you believe that um
the administration should push facebook
to delete
accounts and and stop the spread of
misinformation and that if you're off
facebook as jen saki said you should be
off twitter you should be off youtube
and you should be off all the social
media companies
that's an extraordinary power you're
giving the federal government but i
guess we're going to have to take out
joe biden
so joe you know it's it's been nice
knowing you but you've been exposed as
an agent of misinformation you blatantly
lied in your campaign launch video from
you know roughly two years ago
you lied about what trump said you you
know part of lying is when you just
ignore something right lying isn't just
a blatant oh he said this it's also what
what you
not saying that he said which is exactly
what trump did there
these are not good people and again i
think you get what i'm doing here
and uh and share that little two-minute
snippet you know i'm gonna put it on
twitter
just that sort of minute-and-a-half
snippet where i take what joe said today
what biden's campaign video was and what
trump's answer was we're going to make a
nice tight version of that
so that you can show that to people and
say oh was the very fine
people thing honest and is joe biden
lying and
if these people are working with the
administration we got a problem
we got a bomb all right let's talk about
the clowns over at cnn so brian stelter
as you guys know he hosts
reliable sources i mean this is i say it
all the time it's the most
ironically named television show
ever i mean it is it should be called
unreliable sources then you got a solid
show i'll never talk about it again like
a little honesty in the in the title
would be nice
well anyway brian stelter had uh author
michael wolf on now michael wolf has
written a couple books
about donald trump that are sort of that
i think at times have been debunked i i
don't think this guy is anyone sort of
spectacular but he sort of deserves
cnn and and cnn deserves him and anyway
he went on stelter's show yesterday
and absolutely wrecked him on live
tv so well get popcorn and
take a look i think the media has done a
terrible job on this
i think you yourself um you know why
you're a nice guy you know you're full
of sanctimony
um you know you become part of one of
the parts of the problem of the media
you know you come on here and you and
you have a um
um you know a monopoly on truth you know
you know exactly how things are supposed
to be done
um you know you are why one of the
reasons people can't stand the media
i'm sorry
you're cracking me up it's your fault
it's how so
what should i do differently michael
you know don't talk so much listen more
you know people have genuine problems
with it with
with the media the media doesn't get the
story right
the media exists in its own bubble
um that's true
um you know you gotta stop i mean that
last segment that
that that i just had to listen to of all
of the people saying the same old stuff
also you're incredibly repetitive it's
week after week i mean
you're the flip side of of of of donald
trump
um you know fake news and you say
virtuous news
you know i they're they're not they just
figure out what is real i mean
well well figuring out yeah figuring out
what is real is not so
is not so uh it's not so easy and and
you know most people don't want to talk
turn to brian stelter to tell us what's
real
i'm sorry most people don't want to turn
to brian stelter to tell us what's real
i'm sorry okay so first off again this
michael wolff guy i don't want to make
it about him
he's written a couple over-the-top books
about donald trump that some of the i
think the book that came out during the
administration was heavily debunked so
it's not really about him what's nice
about this though
is that every now and again every now
and again
something true can actually come through
the airwaves
in essence of course what wolf is saying
there is true you stelter are part of
the problem
and what does stelter do he's laughing
he's laughing and then his line is
you're cracking me up
you're cracking me up imagine if i was
on air with someone
and they just started full-on assaulting
my very
integrity and everything that i do you
think i'd be ready to fight back you
think anyone
with any wherewithal with any belief in
what they were doing
uh would actually push back no
i am not that i am not a fraud i am not
a liar
etc etc but stelter's really got
nothing he's just got nothing and then
the way he talks about them being
repetitive
and everything else so again i know that
their ratings are in the tank and it's
one of those things you know how often
do we have to expose them versus by
talking about them are we giving more
air to them
and that whole thing but it is nice to
know that there was
some blue-pilled person that watches the
brian stelter
reliable sources program that was
watching it yesterday morning
that heard something somewhat true on
cnn because you ain't going to hear
anything else true on cnn
now that all being said we have a
cracked
team of researchers here and video
editors
here at the reuben report professional
people doing professional things all day
long
and we put together a little something
special
related to that video here you go i
think you yourself
um you know why you're a nice guy you
know you're full of sanctimony
um you know you become part of one of
the parts of the problem
of the media you are why one of the
reasons
people can't stay in the media i'm sorry
you're cracking me up you know don't
talk so much listen more
you know most people don't want to talk
turn to brian stelter to tell us what's
real
i'm sorry
[Music]
look you might say dave you're above
that and
the ant the truth is no i'm not above
that he's humpty dumpty he's half humpty
dumpty half potato
pretending to be a newsman on cnn and he
deserves
the humor that we bring to it all right
we got one more story for you this one
is really just crazy and it's such
a sign of the times and it's such a
perfect example of why
social justice and wokism as they are
being packaged
and infecting our entire system why they
are so deeply dangerous because we
they are going to take out every
institution they are going to infect
everything that brings us together and
we're going to be turning on each other
if we're if you think we're turning on
each other now
until we break the back of wokism until
we actually reject it all together in
unison
it is going to continue to destroy every
bond that brings us together as
americans
uh so yes they are going to be playing
the black
national anthem at nfl games this is
absolutely bananas i've got some quotes
here from
former sports network now racial justice
network espn
lift every voice and sing traditionally
known as the black
national anthem is expected to be
performed
live or played before every week one
nfl game and the league is considering a
variety of
other measures during the upcoming
season to recognize victims of police
brutality
a source familiar with the league's
discussions told the undefeated
on thursday having recently displayed
increased awareness about problems of
systemic racism the nfl in collaboration
with the nfl players association is also
considering listing the names of victims
on uniforms through decals on helmets
or patches on jerseys the nfl also may
produce
educational programs about victims among
other plans
early last month commissioner roger
goodell in a video admitted that the
league had erred in how it handled
peaceful nfl player protests
of police brutality and systemic
oppression goodell condemned racism and
affirmed that black lives matter
pledging his allegiance to the players
in the battle
for equal justice under the law also in
june the league revealed plans to
increase its social justice footprint
by pledging to donate 250 million
dollars over a ten
year period now first off i would like
to say that roger goodell
you've got good in your name you're a
good man and you should step down
because
as a white man surely roger
there must be a black man who could do
that job so don't just be about
diversity and inclusion let's get a
black man
in that job you've got plenty of money
go retire
go move to wherever it is that old rich
white people move
play golf do your thing be a true
wokester and social justice warrior
uh joking aside guy this is so dangerous
this is so absolutely dangerous first
off
we have one national anthem let's just
be very clear about that we are a nation
and if we are one thing it is americans
here and it doesn't mean we have to
agree on everything
obviously but we now have a virus in the
system
that is here to destroy the whole damn
thing and just try to imagine
so you go to an nfl game week one right
and they play the black national anthem
now first off is everyone supposed to
stand for the black national anthem or
are only black people supposed to stand
for it
do i have to pledge allegiance to the
black national anthem do i have to put
my hand
over my heart so now are some people
gonna stand and some people are gonna
sit
and then what happens and here's the
really sort of insidious part of this
thing
so okay they're going to play the black
national anthem first now first
also just the phrase black national
anthem you could have a song that is
that is sort of about black history or
something like that whether or not it
should be played at a
at a sporting event is a separate thing
but a black nationalism implies that
they have a separate nation
and that is a big problem we have one
nation under god it's in the documents
right okay
but the bigger problem is okay so they
play the black national anthem now
they're going to play the
uh regular national anthem the thing
that we've been playing for hundreds of
years before sporting events and other
sort of big events here uh in america uh
well now are the people that just
pledged allegiance to the other national
anthem are they gonna sit down
are they not gonna you know put the hand
over the heart are they not gonna
sing or recite or anything else this is
designed
to rip us apart and then of course the
league
which is gonna put 250 million dollars
over a 10-year period towards black
lives matter and other
social justice causes i mean black lives
matter which just came out in essence in
support of the government of cuba as
it's repressing its people
and is an avowed marxist organization i
know they deleted that part from the
website but i think you guys know what's
up
um it's designed to destroy everything
so
to be quite honest uh if i was an nfl
fan i'm i don't really care about
football it's not really my thing i
actually
i mean i watch the super bowl but like i
pretty much that's it
it's like i'm kind of over it all
together like it's not even worth
watching that at this point so let these
things
destroy themselves and if a bunch of
people who make millions and millions of
dollars
a year to play football want to sit for
the national
anthem want to sing their special anthem
uh you know want to ignore the flag or
turn their back to it or or all the
series of things that you can do
this will just destroy us even further
there will be fans
looking at other fans in the audience
going he's not singing the black
national anthem i mean should black
people in the crowd be allowed
to yell at white people for not pledging
allegiance to the black national anthem
should
white people be angry at black people
who sang for the black national anthem
but then sit for the regular national
anthem
it's designed to divide and destroy and
i'm here to build
and uh to to make sure that we don't
destroy this whole damn thing and that's
why i like that you're on this journey
with me
uh guys part one of my interview with
robert barnes
who is a spectacular lawyer fighting the
good fight on so many free speech fronts
we really get into the nitty-gritty on
trump's class action lawsuit
against big tech so you really want to
check that out part one is up on youtube
right now
the full is up uh ad free over at
reubenreport.locals.com
and then later today i am interviewing
larry elder in studio now i didn't
mention it up top
but just this weekend so you know that
larry elder announced last week
last monday a week ago today actually
but he was running for governor
of california he filled out all the
paperwork campaign launched he's
actually getting some decent momentum
he had an absolutely ridiculous hit
piece in the la times written on him
so you know that that's a sign that
you're making some noise um well it came
out i guess
yesterday that somehow on the official
list of 41 candidates that are running
in the recall election
larry's name is not on there they are
claiming that it is some bizarre
technicality
uh he posted a video this morning saying
that it is an
absolute error and that he did do
everything that they asked and
everything else
so i'm going to interview him today
we're going to do a mini video that we
will get up today addressing that so i
think i'm going to basically be the
first person to be able to talk to larry
about that specifically the rest of the
interview will be out tomorrow and then
throughout the week obviously you know
how i feel about larry if we have a
chance
to save california then it's a guy like
larry elder that can do it
and you would think and i know i'm a
glutton for punishment so maybe you guys
are wiser than me on this one
you would think that if uh a black man
who is uh
you know uh upstanding member of society
and everything else
was running for governor and he was a
lefty and then a strange technicality
kept him out of the election uh you'd
think that the aclu
and all of the naacp and
al sharpton and the race-baiters at
msnbc they'd be all about screaming wait
a minute wait a minute
the broken evil machine the election
machine
doesn't want this black man to run for
governor we must do something about it
let's march let's link arms they're
stopping a black man from running
but you hear that ah yes those are
crickets
we should have a cricket sound for now
on can we get the cricket sound those
are crickets because of course
they don't want larry elder in the race
and california is so deeply corrupt that
maybe they're going to get him on this
technicality
you have a deeply deeply corrupt state
so it's like they know there's one guy
who's a threat right it's not caitlyn
jenner that's a threat there's one legit
threat who has name recognition and who
has a
broad base and as a media superstar and
everything else and they may try to get
him on his technicalities anyway we will
discuss it
later today and if you want to play
along with everything else that i'm
doing
uh join us at reubenreport.locals.com
oh and then later this week i will be at
freedom fest for a couple days going to
south dakota
uh for freedom fest i'm looking forward
to that and i think larry elder's going
to be there and some of my other friends
are going to be there ayan hercieli and
michael shermer and a bunch of other
people and i'm giving a couple talks on
thursday is that right
couple talks on thursday so i hope to
see some of you guys there anyway have a
great day everybody let's uh let's kick
off the week on the right foot
and i'll see you tomorrow